alors un autre phénomène de société bien
différent il s'adresse peut-être à un
autre type de clientèle si j'ose dire
c'est ce fameux petit bonhomme on peut
appeler ça comme ça
c'est un phénomène de société c'est un
animal virtuel
c'est en tout cas comme ça qu'il est
défini ne souriez pas il ya 15 millions
d'enfants 15 millions d'enfants dans le
monde qui ont acheté ce petit objet et
info ou intox vous allez voir quand on
voit le reportage que nous ont préparés
se figer ou verrai mon chat plat on
n'avait pas vraiment y croire mais c'est
vraiment de l'info ce phénomène teuma
gauchy août à ma gauche exactement
existe bien
regardez le reportage de sophie elles
sont débarqués du japon les bestioles
virtuel et depuis la rentrée leur secte
a fait de nouveaux adeptes qui essaient
désespérément de s'en sortir
est ce que vous faites pas trop manger
mais il ya eu un tamagotchi et elle est
en train de nourrir
moi je regarde tu admires hatier parce
que j'ai essayé de m'en occuper et
malheureusement j'avais celui de ma
grande fille il est décédé j'étais
traîtrise le voilà on a enlevé les piles
on lui a fait un petit cercueil voyez on
attend là j'ai pas le courage de le
faire revivre
pas maintenant c'était prouvant comme
l'expérience et éprouvant parce que je
travaille quand même donc il fallait que
je le confie à mon mari le matin qui
m'appelait affolé à mon travail sonne
qu'est ce que je dois faire et la fim
crottes qu'est-ce que je te perds au
bout de quelques jours il a pris le riz
et puis moi je devais m'occuper du reste
du temps en effet les week-ends
le bébé est exigeant écrit pour être
nourri toile été cajolés du coup un
grand nombre d'écoles les ont interdit à
bagneux tous les collèges les ont banni
c'est quoi comme animal tu continues à
la porte à l'école ouais pourquoi tu
continues à face ils ont lâché les
bombes à si on lui donne pas à manger
peut mourir
on a interdit les tamagotchi dans votre
école il s'agit ne vous à peu créé des
disputes
vous trouvez que c'est bien aussi une
bonne décision d'avoir interdit voilà
même si au fond des poches quelques
tamagotchi sommeil tant corse est
aujourd'hui dans le plus grand secret
est ce que tu es là vous en parlez vous
en disent qu'ils en ont fait non pas du
tout je ne sais pas ce que sont devenus
non alors quelqu'un d'autre doit s'en
occuper c'est ce que j'imagine
et vous savez si les parents ont pris la
relève pas du tout pas du tout j'espère
sinon ils sont morts nourrissent de
profession nelly élèves d'aujourd'hui un
enfant supplémentaire
le bébé virtuel abandonné par sa fille
et la fin ça y est t'es content histoire
comme en ce moment
baïla huit jours il fait 40 kg et il a
bien mangé
il est propre et il est content c'est
autant de travail qu'un enfant
finalement à garder non tout à fait dans
les enfants les nourrit pas d'appuyer
sur les boutons la bester capricieuse
finira par mourir
de quoi décourager les parents méfie
trouvé ça sympa et c'est est contente et
c'est maman qui avait tout le travail
alors quitte à avoir tout le travail
mais je préfère avoir un petit chien
c'est c'est vraiment ce qu'il ya de
mieux pour un enfant c'est là où on peut
donner le plus de temps dans combien
ce chien dans la vitrine ce joli petit
chien jaune et blanc
puis donne à manger je lave je joue avec
et puis je sois une cantine est malade
nancy n'a pas échappé à la folie
tamagotchi les petits animaux
électronique venus du japon se vendent
comme des petits pains depuis trois mois
ils font tout comme les vrais et gare à
celui qui ne s'occupe pas d'eux
après j'avais trop lourd et le
tamagotchi est avant tout un jeu
principe garder le plus longtemps
possible ce petit compagnon
une attention de tous les instants est
requise le tamagotchi se manifeste à la
moindre contrariété un peu comme un vrai
animal domestique and animals réel ça
peut-être vous vous êtes reconnaissants
vont s'annoncer pas reconnaissants dit
fou ça vous ennuie à n'importe quelle
heure de la journée mais c'est pas
reconnaissants mais c'est très drôle
drôle pour ceux désireux lui consacrer
du temps il ne faut pas vraiment
promener acheter de la nourriture aux
tamagotchi mais s'en occuper demande de
la volonté
j'avais entendu parler je sais pas si ça
plaît à vos gosses mais ça leur plaît ça
leur plaît à l'animal virtuel c'est pas
comme un vrai animal où on s'occuperait
vraiment
on aimerait vraiment au début je me suis
occupé puis après je les donne à mort
une fois qu'il est mort comme je l'avais
oubliée chez moi que j'étais chez un
copain
et puis ça commence à énerver un peu
donc j'ai c'est comme ça et bien c'est
d'accord je le prends
[Musique]